make way for John Smoltz Fox Sports and
called the World Series last night where
are you right now John I am still in
Houston got a little delay waiting to
get back to to Atlanta so that I can
crawl in bed for three days and
hibernate
anybody recognize you at the airport
well I finally pulled a Dan Patrick and
I'm flying private I'm flying private
whoa John Smoltz lying fraud yeah I got
some buddies back home Fox Ridge they're
kind enough to offer me a ride home so I
took it yeah but Joe Buck flies private
all the time he does but he goes in
different directions you know currently
you will be in Arizona getting ready to
call the San Francisco 49ers and
Cardinals game tonight I thought that it
would be good every once in a while to
maybe show up in the booth between him
and Troy and just you know pretend like
we're continuing what we got in the
World Series
just follow Jill buck around wherever he
goes you just stay with him that's right
it is it is is good it's good to be Joe
but you did a great job you really did a
wonderful job and I'm not surprised but
you know the beauty of what you do is
it's it's subtle and that is you don't
you act like a know-it-all you sort of
talk to us and take us through it and
you have an opinion in the moment and
especially that moment with Zack Greinke
because Paulie sent out attacks and he
goes what would you do right now and
this is after the home run and then I
said I I would I'd leave in Greinke
because he's only thrown 80 pitches but
but I if I'm changing and taking out
drinking I'm bringing in Gerrit Cole not
Harris so that was what my call was in
the moment but what did you think after
the home run to Rend own what did you
think that AJ Hinch should have done
yeah you know first of all I want to
create maybe you can help me with this I
want to create an app
a live app so that we can eliminate all
second guessing and we can have live
entries to what everyone thinks
especially an analytical world and what
everybody thinks should happen so then
we've got it documented yeah and I think
and and then there's no way that
somebody could say and be right all the
time by second-guessing so we got to
create first of all we got to create
that app because it would be then it
would put people on notice right away
say I was right around was wrong this is
what I would do but having said that I
John John we call it first guess not
second guess we call it first guess and
you got 30 seconds and then that's it
and therefore that's correct it's there
and you can show everybody this is what
I said in the moment because that's what
we do all the time you know Paulie will
always send something out and you'll go
all right what do you do and you got to
do it before it because I see the result
if Harris strikes out the side
I still either would have kept in
Greinke or I would have gone to gear I
can't I can't lose the World Series John
with Gerrit Cole not getting in the game
right and so here's this it was the only
window in the game where Garrett Kohl's
chances of success were not at its
greatest and the reason I say that is
because Garrett Kohl's never pissed off
the bullpen the greatest thing you can
do to him is keep him in a you know
controlled inning meaning start the
inning and then he has the ability to
pitch an inning or two at the max and so
that one small window was the only time
that Gerrit Cole would not have been
able to be ready soon enough to come
into an environment that is not normal
to him is similar to what even with Jill
mad you know didn't want to do when he
brought in John lustrous and I will not
bring in John luster in the World Series
with runners on I will not do in the
moment he ended up doing it and the kind
of backfired but they won the game
anyways with Harris and the job that he
had done all postseason aim was their
best reliever I really believe that was
the right move
no can given the fact that Greg key now
you're talking about a guy who hadn't
gone five innings he was pissing a
phenomenal game and it's easy to say
leave him in and I if that was a
regular-season game it would be a
no-brainer he would have stayed in but
you're talking about one of the
gardius best offenses under the gun in
Washington and they were getting a lot
of looks and so I think for what that
scenario called I have no problem
bringing in Harris who really what you
think about the home run he gave up I
mean how many times is that going to
happen on an outside pitch where the
ball you know hits a foul ball it's just
the nature of the game but Garrett holds
opportunity to pitch that next inning
would have been great had they even tied
it up or only got that one run so what's
really the smallest window where Derek
hole you know that was the only window
where he wasn't going to pitch and in
that game what's your lasting memory
gonna be in this world series I think
it's going to be the lasting memories
this truly was one of the greatest team
efforts I have ever seen in any sport
when you think about their journey I
mean it's real easy I mean I think about
you know somebody telling me in 1991
John you're 2 and 11 at the first half
if you're going to end up pitching the
three most significant games in Braves
history I said yeah I might check you
into some kind of facility right now and
if you just said the same thing with the
alhasan Nationals in 19 and 31 you are
going to have five or six elimination
games you're gonna win you're going to
come back and every one of those you're
gonna beat Josh hater when he's in the
game and I mean just everything that
they went through I I don't know of a
greater World Series winner I mean I'm
sure there's bigger upsets there's
bigger underdogs just their journey and
and how many times they were basically
done now all you can point to LA that
game was over and yet they found ways
Howie Kendrick and my lasting impression
of this team is going to be you can't
quantify things anymore in this game you
can't say age you can't say this is the
way you play what I love about baseball
is that in a unique way they did it with
starting pitching they did it with an
older team they basically did it with
the it factor of inside that Clubhouse
that that manager and those players knew
they had something special and it's
easy to say we never gave up on
ourselves but don't kid yourself for a
minute thinking that there weren't a lot
of self doubts going on but they truly
never gave in to them and look they beat
a great team the Houston Astros were a
great team and I don't think anybody
gave Washington must have a chance
talking to John Smoltz Fox Sports fresh
off the World Series
we had Kevin Millar last hour he thinks
that Strasburg may will opt out but may
stay with Washington anything scared
Cole ends up with the angels and Rendon
ends up with the Rangers what did you
hear yeah I I luckily am NOT not close
in that world but I hope I do hope that
whatever happens with Strasburg that he
ends up somehow staying in Washington I
think that would be a great thing
as far as Gerrit Cole I mean he had the
greatest year at the greatest time and
he's gonna get the greatest content you
know it's good for him and everything
that he has kind of been through I think
all the way back to Gerrit Cole and
again talking about when people were
coming out saying this guy doesn't
strike out enough guys he doesn't do
this he doesn't do that he was in a
different philosophy well they're not
saying that now and he's an organization
game changer but the question will be
you know how can you surround him with
based on that contract and who again
will he go to so rindo you're not gonna
go if he won the lotto or he just lost
his third dog he has a quiet demeanor
about him he's one of those great
underappreciated players so he were to
is going to impact an organization
somewhere we had Joe Girardi on
yesterday and he said something I'd
never heard before you know we were
talking about the controversial play
with traitor nerd first base and in game
six and he said why don't we extend the
first base bag into foul territory let's
just stretch it and make it you know go
into foul territory so the runner doesnt
the runner has to go into fair territory
to get to the bag right yeah but what do
you think I'm extending that I've been
saying that for a long time
and I've I've been accused of a lot of
weird ideas to try and solve issues that
seem so simply easily to solve but have
a different look to it and I really
believe the reason that hasn't happened
there's one tricky part to it first of
all I don't think baseball my opinion
may want to look a base look like that
or be kind of compared to softball but I
don't know I could be that could be a
wrong guess but then you have the
trickiness of the ball going over the
bag you'd have to have a line over the
bag because that's one of the arguments
I heard of why it wouldn't be as easily
done because then you got to determine
where that ball went over the bag would
be in foul territory so but I totally
agree with that I think it would
alleviate the essence of the one of the
most controversial rules the letter of
the law clearly states what it is but
then it becomes a judgement call and of
course when a million people look at one
thing I'm gonna see it a bunch of
different ways so that would help
we had Dave pallone on yesterday and the
former baseball umpire he did not like
my called third strike if I was an
umpire he didn't know I think I would
like it let me see what he got oh yeah
he said it was too long because he said
he would always go so can I can I just
tell you what I can I just tell you what
this whole and and you know let the kids
play and enthusiasm in the ocean I think
I think that we need more umpires like
Naked Gun where you got you know the
umpire behind home why not let's let the
umpires have a motion let's have the
pitchers have them or let's just have a
basic dance party when we get a chance
to do something great so I'm saying let
the umpires really let it let it go and
it wouldn't be too long for me if I
struck somebody out of the mound I'd
love to watch the umpire kind of do his
thing no I know but we're worried about
showing people up tuned
you can't show anybody on them so here
so here's my beauty of this all right so
our pitchers just more mature than why
don't why our pitchers doing it so if if
get the luxury of being able to let
their emotion and let them look listen
pictures be able to do it
oh I'm fine with that you know the
problem I have is when you if I show you
up as a pitcher then you go I'm gonna
throw I'm gonna hit you
you know if Eckersley wants to play it's
all it's an easy sauce so imagine the
pitcher being able to walk down the line
with the guy as he's walking out staring
him down I mean John I'm okay with all
of this the problem is baseball's
old-school and it needs to be new-school
every other sport is evolving and and
there's nothing more fun I'm okay if you
want to carry your damn bat around the
bases like what was it Serrano did in
Major League I'm okay with that too I
don't I don't care this oh you got a you
got a YouTube after we're done up next
to me
mocking Carlos Perez with the Montreal
Expos okay it's must-see TV okay nobody
thought I was going to be able to do it
it made CNN play of the day back in the
day and you know he had a little shimmy
up every time he struck Sabet and it was
fun and it was this and it was you know
guys would like I said whoa watch I told
my teammates I'm gonna do it to him when
I strike him up he said you don't have
this gun
I said well you watch the very next time
I'm gonna do it and I do this bak shimmy
and the entire dugout for the Expos was
on the ground laughing and so he told
Eddie Perez Marquette sure he said then
I had to face him five days later in
Montreal he said when I strike out
smokes in Montreal I'm going to sit down
on the mound
so Eddie told me that he was going to
step down on the bone I think I had a 9
or 10 pitch at that I fouled off
everything emergency I was not striking
out luckily he didn't sit on the mouth
see it's all a good fun I I know but you
guys take it far too seriously ok I'm ok
with celebrating something baseball
doesn't allow you to celebrate great
things because we're always worried
about how
is this look right well we're gonna have
a little fun I guess not the mouth hey
you did you did well and you'll probably
be at the Sports Emmys there you know
maybe you'll you'll get a Sports Emmy
with that that performance beaut you
were as good as Strasbourg let's put it
that way well that is a fine and a high
compliment and I can just tell you that
I emptied my passion bucket here in
October and I don't have anything left
you know I just left it on the field how
about that and you're the Greg Maddux of
an out of baseball analyst I tell you I
am looking forward to not doing anything
safe travels back John thanks for
joining us as always hi buddy
thank you that's John Smoltz he is a
professional for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]